hi everyone I'm Rob and welcome to my
tutorial on how to make an origami gift
box in this tutorial I will teach you
how to make the gift box using a piece
of square paper I'm going to be using
printer paper but if you have origami or
any type of square paper that should be
fine also if you're going to be using
printer paper like I am what you want to
do is you want to take this corner fold
it down so that this edge is aligned
with the side and you want to cut off
the excess paper so that you have
something like this when you open it up
you will have a piece of square paper
that has a diagonal fold going this way
once you have a piece of paper like that
we're going to take this corner now and
we're going to fold it down to this
corner and make sure that everything is
lined up perfectly then you can make a
crease and when you open it you should
have a piece of paper that now has an X
in it to make things a little bit easier
for you to see I've drawn an X in the
center of the paper on the two diagonal
folds which we previously created what
we need to do now is to take each of
these corners and fold them down so that
the tip of the corner is directly on the
center of that X and as you'll see this
diagonal fold should basically be folded
on top of itself so you want it to be
lined up just like that until the tip of
the corner is directly in the middle of
the X just like that and then you can
make a crease and you want to do that
with the remaining three corners when
you're done you should have something
that looks just like this
now we're going to unfold the corners
that we previously folded in towards the
center and now we have formed as we have
formed these creases here in the center
of that crease you'll notice there is a
vertical fold and the two meet right
there at the little plus symbol what we
want to do is we want to take the
opposite corner meaning we want to take
this corner and we're going to fold it
directly into the middle of that plus
and we're going to do that for each of
the four corners so you want to take the
corner and you're going to fold it all
the way up until it meets the middle of
that plus and then you're going to make
a crease you should have something that
looks just like that then you're going
to unfold that and you're going to do
the same for the other corners
so when you're done you should have
something that looks just like this
okay so this next part is going to be a
little bit tricky but as usual I'm going
to go through in as much detail as I can
to make things as simple for you as
possible the size of the box as you'll
see is the same size as this inner box
this inner square that I have outlined
here if you would like to draw the lines
that I have here it might help you in
making the next folds what we're going
to do now is we're going to work on the
wall or the corner of the box basically
this area right here we're going to be
working on what we need to do is we need
to lift up these two top corners so
we're going to be lifting up these two
top corners along these folds here so
you want to lift them up and as you'll
see that little area that I have marked
off the V with this dotted line that
should it should kind of fold downwards
and it will crease along that dotted
line now I'm sure that many of you are
lifting up the corners and you're
getting something like that you're like
no it's not doing that well it's a
little bit tough if you don't have
really really good creases along these
lines so what you do fold it along this
line here take your fingernail and run
it down that crease as hard as you can
open it and do the same along this line
here run your finger now against it okay
now when you lift up these two flaps
just kind of gently push here and you'll
see that should kind of fold in just
like that and that's exactly what you
want it to look like okay so I'm gonna
start with this one I'm going to go
through how to do one corner and then
you're going to go through the rest
because they're identical it's a little
bit hard for me to show this on camera
because when I start making these folds
this parts gonna get in the way so what
you want to do you're going to lift up
the corners
along these lines here so lift it up
just like that and as you'll see mine
has been tucked in just like it should
be along that dotted line what I want to
do now is I'm going to crease that
dotted line just like that so as you'll
see I have created a corner or a wall
there so now what we want to do I'm
going to lay this flat like this I'm
going to fold this edge here that has
the dotted line on it I'm going to fold
it onto this line here of the wall so I
want to take it I'm going to fold it so
that dotted line is along the corner of
the wall here and then I want to make a
crease make a really good crease so if
you want to run your fingernail against
that one also you could do that unfold
it then we're going to take this edge of
the triangle and we're going to fold it
onto that same line so we're going to
fold it upwards like that and you want
to fold it just like that onto that line
so when you unfold it you should notice
that we have two creases now one's going
like this and the other one is going
like this so you should have something
that looks just like that okay so to get
a really good angle on this part right
here I had to cut off the other
remaining parts of the box so I just
have this one corner I'm going to show
you how to do in detail what you should
have is something that looks just like
this and as you'll see I drew two lines
here where we made those two creases and
I've done the same on the other side so
what you want to do is you want to have
these two corners flat on the table and
you want this sticking straight up in
the air
you want to make sure that these edges
underneath here are directly together
just like that you want to open this
pocket here of this triangle and you
want to push straight down on that
dotted line I drew so that that dotted
line is directly in the middle of those
two edges and then you want to crease on
both sides so that that is flat okay so
now that you have this little triangle
flattened out you'll notice if you look
close up that there is a fold or crease
leading from the corner of this line
directly to the center of the dotted
line here on the bottom so if you draw
two lines like that it might make this
next fold a little bit easier what we're
going to do is we're going to lift this
up and you want to tuck this corner you
want to tuck it in words just like that
so if you fold this edge here this edge
if you fold it on the midline like that
and then you kind of push it up all the
way you'll notice that it will Bend on
that line that I drew and then just
flatten out that crease do the same with
the left side so as you'll see there is
a crease right here and you want to fold
on that crease so that this edge is on
the midline keep going all the way up
keep folding along the edge here until
that whole edge folds all the way up to
the top and it makes a point so you
should have something that looks just
like that then what you want to do is
you want to just push down on that point
so that it's facing towards you
so you should have something that looks
just like this okay so we've pretty much
finished the first corner of the box
what you want to do now that you have
something that looks like this is you
want to fold along this crease here you
want to fold this flap outwards and down
and you want to do the same with this
one
so fold along this line here all the way
down as you'll see you should have a
triangle sticking up just like that what
you want to do is you just want to take
the tip and you want to fold it inwards
as far as it can go so that it is level
with the height of the box and then what
you want to do is to just kind of pinch
the corner just like that and you have
finished making one corner of the box so
you need to do that with the remaining
three corners okay so if you've done the
same procedure with the remaining three
corners you should have something that
looks just like this what we're going to
do now is we're just going to fold these
flaps of the box so that we can actually
interlock them so what you want to do is
you'll see this dotted line you want to
take this side of the flap and you want
to fold it so that this corner meets
this corner right here basically we're
going to be folding on that dotted line
so when you fold it down you'll notice
this edge will align with this edge and
this corner will meet this corner right
here so you fold it just like that and
then you make a crease so your flap
should look just like that you want to
do that with the remaining three flaps
so you should have a box that looks just
like this okay so the final step of
making the origami gift box is to
interlock the flaps now since we folded
this to the left we need to go in a
counterclockwise direction if you folded
it to the right like that then you can
go in a clockwise direction but I'm not
going to try to confuse you so I'm going
to start with the bottom flap and I'm
going to fold that in first you might
need to make some
here on the outside of the box also so
you start with the bottom one then you
go in a counterclockwise direction so
number two is the flap to the right one
two fold the top flap down on top of
that which is three now the last flap is
going to go over the third flap and
underneath the first flap so you got to
tuck it in right here so it's going to
go then but you could bend it a little
bit to make it easier I'm going to go
over the third flap and under the first
flap so it's going to look something
just like that and as always you might
have to make some creases there so I
hope you guys enjoyed the tutorial for
how to make the origami gift box and
please comment rate and subscribe for
future notification of my videos thanks
for watching